how much
did jackass 3d with the
the we man's chronic tacos logo that
they included
in the film how much did that launch
your
your restaurant enterprise it launched
it huge
it was a big success i hear about it
still to this day
because films forever so somebody
watching it last night
we'll see the women you know ryan dunn's
jump sponsored by we man's chronic tacos
and you didn't even have to do the jump
[Laughter]
it's so great
and so so you had already gotten in to
that deal
right and i was already in i'd already
been in two years deep
once the movie hit and it was um
just one restaurant that had my name on
yeah was that newport no that was uh
redondo beach
and and we did it we did it just for fun
and knoxville would drive by it all the
time when he used to go to naomi's house
so he said when he first saw the sign go
up he sent me a picture and he goes what
the hell's going
on and i'm like yeah just doing what i
do bud
and was that the first chronic tacos
no no no there was 28 at that time oh
[__] okay
so when so when you here's here's what
happened
so in 2008 uh the founder
came to me and asked uh
hey do you want to join chronic tacos
we're we're kind of either in the middle
of going to
sell the brand or maybe revamp it and he
goes i've seen you
you do some cool things i think you
could be a cool face for it and i said
well let's meet and you know discuss
so we met and then we had a great time
we hit it off
he's such a rad dude his name's randy
and
we ju he goes dude let's the one you
open let's call it we man's chronic
talkers i'm like
all right i wasn't even involved in
making that decision
i just wanted to be part of the brand
and we did that and then
it kind of it spiraled from there right
what i wasn't
clear on was what why you had your name
on one restaurant
but you actually have like some kind of
uh
involvement in owning all of them right
you've got like a share of it
yep i'm uh 10 of the whole thing oh
[__] he gave us a number that's pretty
good
dude and now there's 50 restaurants no
there's 62. we're
oh [__] they did it added like 12 in the
last few months
are you guys killing it right now is are
you guys taking a huge hit with the rona
are you guys worried about it we're
we're taking a huge hit with the rona
we're i can admit that we're taking a
hit with this but it you know we're
doing like everybody else's curbside
pickup
and deliveries right so you know how you
guys would do a lot better it would be
doing some hot sauce for your butthole
inside of each store
i mean if you can make some decisions
let's [__] talk about it
yeah i mean how many different styles of
your own hot sauce do you have
we have uh two or three different styles
i mean you could add hot sauce for your
bun
[Laughter]
and it's so funny too that um i think it
was preston
he like when your restaurant business
really took off
he said yeah we got a new name for we
man
he's rich little
[Laughter]
yeah ah that's great it's great congrats
on that too man
to just said to set yourself up i feel
like
it's shocking nobody would ever believe
like that
actually like the jackass guys have like
reasonably high iqs
you know for the most part
you've always made pretty uh pretty good
decisions i think
like with with money with business you
know like
and um the housing market yeah
[__] dude oh my god dude with the house
dude
you should be your financial advisor
yeah i know dude
i've been off i didn't know what's funny
is i've actually been reading
finance books lately too
and i've got some pretty good advice and
big changes that once
once this whole thing kind of goes
through
there's going to be some big changes to
happen and i want to pass the word onto
it especially
like my bros get ready this is gonna be
gnarly
pretty gnarly kind of normal are we
ready yeah
what's up denver
[Music]
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [__] up
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're gonna hurt me you're gonna piss
me off